Speaker 1: You know, yesterday we had
clips from this Texas Tribune event in
which California Governor Gavin Newsom was
striking the exact right tone and moral
clarity when it comes to Republican Governor
Ron DeSantis, his Martha's Vineyard immigrant
stunt. But Gavin Newsom correctly pointing
out this is disgusting. This is using people,
this is bullying and I'm against this. I'm
against this. And I believe that he did a
great job of using the right language and
tone that Democrats need to use. Let's not
shy away from the fact that the left does
have the moral high ground on most issues
when compared to these completely amoral right
wingers. Well, I have another clip from that
very same event, and it's of Transportation
Secretary Pete Buttigieg. And again, I've
mentioned yesterday, I mentioned there are certain
people right now in the Democratic Party that know
how to talk about these issues. Gavin Newsom is
one of them. I've talked about Katie Porter to
some degree. We've talked about Stacey Abrams and
Jamie Raskin. Pete Buttigieg is also one of those
folks. And here is Pete talking about the Ron
DeSantis stunt. We need more Democrats talking
about issues in this way. Take a look at this.
Speaker 2: Obviously there are issues with the
border and with migration, but
these are the kinds of stunts
you see from people who don't
have a solution. Right. But.
We're easily governor understands this was
in Congress. Where was he when they were
debating immigration reform? What have any of
these people done to be part of the solution?
So, you know, again, if you're after attention,
it's one thing to call attention to a problem.
When you have a course of action, as
some of the folks here are speaking.
Speaker 3: Of, about an issue exercising
their First Amendment rights up on
or in elected office, it's another.
Speaker 2: To just call attention to
a problem because the problem
is actually more useful to you
than the solution. And that helps you
call attention to yourself. Correct.
That's what's going on. And the
problem, of course, is it's one.
Speaker 3: Thing if that was
just people being obnoxious,
but human beings are being impacted. If you flee
a communist regime in Venezuela, you come here
and then somebody tricks you with somebody
using Florida taxpayer money for some reason,
tricks you into going from Texas to Massachusetts.
It's it's it's not just ineffectual. It is
hurting people in order to get attention.
Speaker 1: It is morally depraved. What was done.
In other words, we need more Democrats talking
about issues in this way. What Gavin Newsom and
Mayor Pete. Secretary of transportation.
He'll always be mayor pete to some degree.
What Newsom and Mayor Pete captured here is the
essence of how bad faith these Republicans are.
I joke around about, you know, this guy has
upper management written all over him. There
is some sense that Pete Voodoo Judge is not going
to peek at secretary of transportation because he
is really good at this. And unfortunately, we
still have a situation where people judge him
for who he loves, the fact that he's married
to a guy, I believe that that is going to be a
diminishing impediment for Mayor Pete over time. I
don't know how soon and I don't know how quickly.
But what's interesting is I actually have some
sort of center, center right. I have some sort
of like socially liberal, but typically Republican
voting friends for fiscal reasons who, you know,
they like Mitt Romney, for example. They they kind
of like the McCain who like Pete, not because they
agree or disagree so much with his social views
or his economic views, but because they feel that
he strikes the right tone and brings the right
energy and is of an interesting generation to
be in a position of power. And so I actually
believe that, particularly as, quite frankly,
overt homophobia hopefully continues to diminish.
I think people the judge has a real shot at higher
office than where he is now, which is secretary of
transportation, doing a really good job there. And
I'm glad to see more Democrats actually talking
about issues in this way. It's necessary. We
have the moral high ground. There's no reason
to lose the rhetoric game. It's just we have
to know how to talk about the issues. And
some of these guys and gals absolutely do.